foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the MCU body count where we
tally up the victims of all our favorite
Marvel heroes I'm Vera Wilde and today
we're talking about Clint Barton AKA
Hawkeye the character debuted in Tales
of suspense number 57 which came out in
September of 1964. it was created by
writer Stan Lee and artist Don Heck and
was originally a reluctant villain he
was a skilled Archer who'd fallen in
love with Natasha Romanov AKA Black
Widow who was also a Villain at the time
serving as a Soviet operative and
primarily going up against Iron Man with
Hawkeye as her backup Hawkeye would have
two more appearances along these lines
before changing sides and joining up
with the heroes in Avengers number 16 in
May of 1965. since then he has been a
fixture of the team only occasionally
getting to be the lead in various
limited series Clint's skill of the bow
came from his time with the traveling
Carnival that he joined after fleeing
the orphanage he was living in that's
right he literally ran away and joined
the circus while there he trained under
the supervillain villain trick shot as
well as The Swordsman who's been both a
villain and a hero at various points in
the comics and appears as more or less a
good guy in the Hawkeye streaming series
but we're not really here to talk about
the comic so we'll move on from that
because we're here to talk about his run
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe as
portrayed by Jeremy Renner as in the
comics Clint's signature weapon is a bow
and arrow making use of both traditional
metal tipped arrows and also various
trick arrows that do what well all
manner of things some deadly some not so
we'll have to see how this shakes out
when they're actually put to use so
let's get to it Hawkeye's first
on-screen appearance is in Thor but not
only are there no kills for him in this
I won't actually be counting it as a
significant appearance at all when it
comes time to do the final numbers it's
just one scene it's effectively an
Easter egg I wouldn't count it for the
same reason that I didn't count Tony
Stark's one scene appearance in The
Incredible Hulk back when I did the Iron
Man body count video so his first
appearance we are moving right on from
this means we jump over to the Avengers
where Clint has his will bent to serve
Loki and does some notable damage in
that state now some may argue that these
kills shouldn't be counted since
Hawkeye's basically under mind control I
am still going to count them though
because as depicted Loki's mind control
doesn't completely override the
personality or behaviors of the people
under his thrall it just redirects those
things to be in service of him if it was
a complete body puppeting situation
region I might not count it but that is
not what's going on here Barton is still
choosing how he goes about his service
to Loki so far as I can tell and how he
operates here is in line with what we
see when he is in his right mind so with
all that established Clint takes out two
guards with arrows while Loki is making
his big splashy debut in Berlin later on
while assaulting The Shield Helicarrier
Hawkeye takes out a couple of Agents
with explosions they would actually
technically be his co-workers under
normal conditions so I'm
I'm sure that made the next company
picnic a little bit awkward once free of
Mind Control Hawkeye takes up a position
to help battle The chatari Invasion
however as I've established in previous
entries I'm only counting sentient
beings as kills and I consider the
chittari to be a hive mind so none of
these kills will be counted if you don't
agree with this approach I went into
full detail of my rationale for this
back in the Iron Man body count video so
feel free to check that out if you feel
inclined to argue that means that
Hawkeye adds nothing to his tally during
the fabled Battle of New York and we now
move on to the next team up movie
Avengers Age of Ultron oh wow this
opening action scene is still a huge
pain in my butt Hawkeye is a little
easier than some of the others to track
just because of the nature of his weapon
if we see an arrow connect with a
non-named villain otherwise referred to
as a henchman a Lackey or a goon it's a
safe assumption that it's a fatal hit
unless we see that person either get
back up or the arrow clearly
definitively hits somewhere non-lethal
like I don't know pinning their hand to
a wall or something so with all that
covered even though Hawkeye appears to
almost never miss most of the time I am
not gonna count every single time he
loses an arrow as a kill I need to be
able to see that it actually hits
somebody and whether or not there is a
clear impact or at least somebody
dropping from what I can safely assume
to Be an Arrow hit if I can't come up
with those things it does not count so
while I have little doubt Hawkeye took
out more than his fair share and more
than I'm gonna count during this
expanded opening shot the ones I can
confirm for sure only come out to four
while riding in the back of the Jeep
there are three kills one being a direct
hit and two more that I am going to
count because we see these guys on
jetpacks drop out of the air from the
points where Clint was aiming his arrows
so I feel that's a safe assumption I
almost counted this hit to the helmet as
a kill but it's accompanied by an
electrical sound effect
which in the auditory language of these
kinds of films generally denotes a stun
Hawkeye also probably took out the
driver of this other Jeep but I can't
rule out the possibility that he shot
the engine or did something else to
disable the vehicle without actually
killing the driver so that doesn't get
counted either later on before the Big
Hero shot he fires multiple arrows but
frankly it's all too chaotic and there's
too much stuff that gets in the way of
the camera for me to be able to tell
what's going on for most of these going
frame by frame there is one goon who
goes down that I'm pretty confident
Clint is responsible for though in
reality it's probably a lot higher than
that once he's out of the Jeep Hawkeye
has black widows back by taking out this
guy from the trees and then Barton blows
up this bunker and the laser cannon
housed there while I don't doubt any
hydra agents inside are indeed killed I
do have to guess on how many that would
be now the bunker is big enough I could
believe four even six but the only
number I'm comfortable with having any
certainty on is two since later in the
assault we see similar cannons manned by
two henchmen since Hawkeye then gets
knocked around by Quicksilver that marks
the end of his confirmed kills in this
opening scene
that brings us to the fight on the tank
or about Midway through the film and
just like before as much as I'd like to
give Hawkeye credit for every arrow
fired I'm only counting the ones where I
see an impact or a body so that gives us
one when Claus goons join the fight we
also get another confirmed takedown a
little bit later in the same fight and
Clint also fires what I think is a Sonic
Hero to take out a cluster of lackeys
but I'm presuming that as a knockout
move so he doesn't get credit for any of
them since the Ultron Bots are
definitely a high of mine it's even more
clear-cut than the chatari none of the
Last Action scene counts Hawkeye next
appears in Civil War as do most of the
established MCU characters at this point
but since he's only participating in
here on hero battles there are no kills
to be counted moving on we're still
friends right she doesn't know how you
hit me you're pulling your punches
Hawkeye was in absentia for Infinity War
but he comes back with a sword and a
mean streak in end game when the film
cuts to Tokyo we come into an action
scene already in progress with by my
count nine bodies on the floor with
Barton working alone I'm actually okay
with crediting him with every single one
of these three more get taken down with
some sort of Throne sharp thing there's
another slashed as Clint goes up the
stairs I am not counting the guy who
gets knocked out the window because I
don't hear any sound effects that sound
like a slash or a stab just the backhand
out the window and it was only one
flight of stairs up so I figure that's a
survivable fall he may have landed on
something that might have killed him but
we don't see that so not gonna count it
we then have clinch Showdown sword fight
where he ultimately claims another kill
with a gut slash a throat slash and a
sword Plunge for good measure good grief
Clint while Hawkeye going by Ronin at
this particular point in his life does
rack up quite the body count at the
start of the film that's gonna be it for
him since during the big climactic fight
scene pretty much anything he takes out
is part of thanos's army which is bulked
out with various mindless beasts and
Hive Minds like the chittari so that's
it for end game now covering Hawkeye
we've also got something new to add to
the body count a six episode limited
miniseries and that show follows Clint
as he meets Archer Kate Bishop the two
become embroiled in crime Shenanigans
and in the first episode Hawkeye takes
out some members of the so-called
tracksuit Mafia but it's a fist fight
and appears to be non-fatal for all
involved second episode involves some
Molotov cocktail throwing but again
nobody gets killed episode 3 gives us a
flashback from the perspective of Maya
Lopez AKA Echo and we see Clint in the
Persona of Ronan kills several members
of the tracksuit Mafia including echo's
father in the flashback Echo returns to
the fat man auto repair shop and we get
our first kill with the man's face
pressed to a small window and the sound
of a sword next up we get a blood
splatter coming across the window from
one unseen source and then we briefly
see another man get cut down so that's
two more since there's space far enough
apart both temporarily and the distance
that the first blood splatter had to be
from somebody other than the man we then
see sliced we promptly get two more
seeing Ronan stab at someone just out of
frame before stabbing backwards to get
another guy Maya then enters the office
where we see another body slashed across
the throat and then her father run
through before Ronan bolts that covers
the flashback and we get to jump to the
present Clinton Kate escaped the
tracksuit Mafia and for the most part
Clint seems to be going for non-lethal
options here that is until he shoots
this guy in the back and then another in
the throat Clint goes hand to hand for a
bit before for taking down two more by
arrow and then disarming this guy with a
little bit of a show-off move but I like
it now we do see that plenty of people
are left alive as Clint and Kate exit
but none of them have arrows sticking
out of their bodies my point in bringing
this up is that there's no movement from
the people who took any of the shots
that I listed so I am going to count all
those as kills even though we see plenty
people were still left behind now it's
car chase time and there are definitely
some fatalities here but with Clint at
the wheel and Kate firing the arrows
Hawkeye does not get credit for these
episode 4 features some very cool if
under lit fights with both Maya and
Elena the sister of the late Black Widow
but since those are named characters who
are going to be used in later projects
going up against the two leads and this
isn't the finale yeah uh no prizes for
realizing none of these characters are
gonna get killed episode 5 features
Clint back in the Ronin costume taking
out goons but none of them are clearly
or definitively killed actually the
whole segment in the parking lot is very
Batman Begins up until Clint takes on
Maya a decently matched fight but no
clear kills there either so let's get to
the finale
the Hawkeye finale also has some good
action including an incredibly awesomely
entertaining fight between Elena and
Kate but since we're focused on Clint
here I can't Linger on that too long as
much as I like it that is a good one
that was good form but you did a really
cool body throw yeah there thank you
stop making me like you
Clint has it out with Maya's traitorous
second in command and that results
initially in just a knockdown now during
this fight he also brings down the
ceiling on a group of goons but none of
them are taken down by the blast itself
and while blunt force trauma to the head
is no joke that blast didn't bring down
the floor above that ceiling so I'm
disinclined to think that what they got
hit with was weighty enough to truly be
fatal after that Clint actually ends up
stuck in the iconic Rockefeller Center
Tree which Kate eventually brings down
so we can rejoin the fight as more of
the tracksuit Mafia closes in this is a
lot of trick arrows so I'm gonna have to
make some judgment calls on what's
liable to result in death but on review
most of the ones I'm inclined to count
as deadly get fired by Kate and
therefore they don't go on the count you
know if I had been keeping track I would
be kind of curious to know if she
actually kills more people than Hawkeye
does in this show
now I I'm not going to go back and check
I actually don't really have the time
but if anybody else wants to check and
let me know that'd be cool as for Clint
he does a freezing Arrow to this guy's
leg and had the the effect of that
climbed up past his upper thigh I might
count this one but as depicted well I
expect he's probably gonna lose that leg
I'm not going to count it as a kill next
there's this stun Arrow which yeah it
stuns so that's not a death there's also
a gas Arrow which appears to be more of
a distraction or possibly a knockout
move it's hard to be sure because the
camera doesn't Linger on it so we don't
really know the effects of this thing
then things go hand to hand for a bit we
hit the slow motion triumphant moment of
this brawl and we finally get a kill for
Clint in the finale of his own dang show
as he takes down a goon with a normal
Arrow right in the chest it is possible
there's some more kills during this
section but we don't see the impact and
effect of every arrow that gets fired
and again I'm only counting what I can
be certain of for instance I think he's
the one who fires this maybe it's a
Sonic maybe it's a concussion Arrow I
don't know but I can't be certain of
that besides it doesn't really look
deadly to me however he does have this
show-offy no aiming shot that causes a
pretty sizable explosion and while none
of the tracksuit Mafia guys are engulfed
by the blast I'm still gonna call that
close enough to be fatal so that adds
three more to the count next when Maya's
second in command shows up again with
two henchmen in tow Clint fires off two
arrows in a row using the second one to
split the first and take out the two
goons Clint himself also survives a
rather thorough beating from Elena and
is able to make it home for Christmas
wrapping up this series and his time in
the MCU for now at least it's possible
he may return but the show also seems to
set up the possibility of him retiring
and for Kate Bishop to take up his bow
possibly even his mantle in future but
only time will tell so we'll wrap up
this count with a nice Christmas bow
let's take a look at how it All Shook
out and run down the numbers by my
account Clint Barton AKA Hawkeye AKA
Ronan AKA Arrow guy ended up with a
total of 44 on-screen kills he
doubtlessly took out way more in his
time as Ronan but again I'm only
counting what we see on screen now this
puts him above Captain America's but
still well behind the current leader
Iron Man Who racked up an impressive 82.
appearing in five films and a six
episode series if I count the series as
a super long film that gives Clint an
average of 7.33 kills per appearance
counting it this way puts him between
Steve and Tony for kill average although
if I count each episode as an appearance
instead of just the series as a single
one that would give Clint an average
body count of 4 4. per appearance and
that would make him the lowest average
of the group so far since counting it
that way means he has the most
appearances to spread his kills out over
for my purposes I'm going to consider
the series as one appearance but I
thought folks might like to know how it
looked to the other way as far as how
Hawkeye took people out it doesn't quite
end up the way you might be expecting
there were seven people taken down by
various forms of explosion including
explosive arrows 16 taken out by more or
less traditional arrows at a whopping 21
cut down with a sword that means Ronan
was such a prolific killer that Clint
actually took out more people with a
sword than with his characters iconic
weapon most of his non-explosive trick
arrows appear to be non-lethal which is
part of why that number is lower than
even I was expecting so there we have it
one more Avengers Legacy of death
accounted for Hawkeye was an interesting
one to cover since his go-to weapon is
probably probably the most lethal by
nature and he spent some time as a flat
out murderous vigilante using something
even deadlier Clint clearly needed his
family to keep him grounded and when
they were gone he went on a rampage with
an extremely harsh sense of justice but
once his family was back he was able to
regain his life as a family man even
though his actions as Roan and still
haunted him as seen in the Hawkeye
series but with Kate ready and eager to
take his place it may finally be time
for him to settle into a quiet life
that's it for this MCU body count in two
months it's going to be a special time
it's gonna be smashing time as we take a
look at the damage and bodies left
behind by Bruce Banner AKA The
Incredible Hulk hope to see you then
so that's Hawkeye what did you think
about this one was it higher than you
thought lower did it break down the way
you expected whatever your thoughts
might be drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it
patreons will pays the bills and enables
me to sync the not inconsiderable amount
of time it takes to make this series
even though it doesn't get particularly
high views I'm gonna finish out this
initial run covering the six original
Avengers I'm gonna do it because I want
to but I couldn't do more passion
projects like this without that support
even if you can't support me that way
like share subscribe also help but what
I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
and credits that means I need to shout
out my top Patron supporters Robin Moore
zupin but fulla to rock the thing that
goes joint in the anime Oliver B Linda
Walters emu Delhi leotha Boyd toy lowly
Becky Sparks bernabe likes the poodle
Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor Shea lugurley Brendan Larose and
TT
thank you so much for your support you
can get your name in the credits too by
checking out the rewards on the patreon
you only try deep my earring once this
time that's much better
[Music]
foreign
[Music]